we should note that Claud and gay has
not been accused of stealing anyone's
ideas she's been accused of sort of a
more like a copying uh other people's
writings it's official clouding gay has
resigned as president of Harvard
University now her supporters say that
gay the first black president of Harvard
is a victim of racist mobs and that her
resignation is an attack on every black
woman in the US others say gay is being
unfairly punished because she defended
the right to say anti-semitic things on
campus that's all wrong it isn't racist
to oppose gay it's hardly some principal
offender of free speech in fact during
her tenure Harvard dropped to dead last
in the annual Free Speech rankings
assembled by fire gay was actually
ousted because she's a plagiarist has
been caught lazily repurposing work by
other Scholars this isn't a new
conservative weapon against colleges
it's Harvard's own policy they should
have held her to the same standard as
any other Professor or student who
commits the same offense now maybe the
university can find a new president who
actually cares about free speech and can
articulate ideas for herself